five oh that's just great I died okay
what are you going where you go I'm
watching your first move that's me baby
so Steve's got his minor Uriel's and
main ingredient on si
Pikachu's got us same with us same as
Craig's load out and this is our
competition is sidearm by de and either
something
oh no let's guys switching it up you
know I do whatever is that good oh [ __ ]
this is like old time we've done this
map like a thousand times
I know off screen and you start who went
out there like Pikachu
there we got Stevie maybe even way we
got a kale and this guy's gopher temple
okay I just died to kill Roger damn
Pikachu don't run out that far we'll go
we'll go power right power right all
right right behind us behind you they
snuck up on demand cow well how are you
guys all down already
I need help [ __ ] yeah we got white
I'm not having fun as much fun as that
was like 20 minutes we just hope we're
not doing I mean these guys are this
desert try hards - how do you know
now we're warming up because showing
this Cady and woman just the guy that
does he doesn't play unless he's got his
boy friends with them that's it that's
why they're all doing this my [ __ ] you
Yeti
[ __ ] you team Yeti we hate you oh man
this guy's got a 9.0 yeah that's not
good little yeah all right they're all
here guys oh well [ __ ]
so they rocked me but I got a grenade in
there heard of the bullet they ran out
one time all three of them all three of
them or that watch out grenade they're
collapsing on us so hey cuz we're not
doing good man it's a war but not a
woman gonna be like the theme of the
night how dude this always happen Adam
we get better dude we talk to me we're
trying here learn that there they're all
there
they're team shooting they're running
that's all they're doing this team QT
yeah I agree
so we gotta work on your own team
shooting wow this sucks
what's he called sweaty yetis yeah hello
is that your [ __ ] I don't know that is
correct
again their house beat but you know it's
this is what we need to do we need to
stay together like they are like one
unit
yeah well that's I say follow coke sorry
alright
they just farm me dude so what so what
do we do what do we do here so we just
leave
no I it doesn't count it doesn't count
the first first game yeah my game
history I didn't even get a win dude
that's embarrassing man so for those who
don't we got the card would start huh
it's good we didn't get a win cuz the
card would have started and we would
have lost oh is that how it works
yeah it's a warm-up let's just do bad we
could do better I think it's because
Steve and Craig are in the sitting room
Steve you leave these voices the only
one I don't know why I think it's cuz
you guys are in the same room yeah we're
in the same room I it's not that bad
yeah but my mic my mic shouldn't be
picking him up though we're pretty we're
not next to each other where's your
mouthpiece is it in the thing oh it's
right here maybe kid is there any way to
put it up higher does have a clip huh no
this is this is what you get that's why
it's my shirt alright no sorry guys it's
a it's a minor echo
yeah thanks McLovin i let's try again
throw us any pointers or strategy some
licorice you got uh some sad you got a
press okay sorry it's my fault
hey check so someone asked what 2029 is
it's a Skype main directions self-aware
and we need to find John Connor so we
can assemble the resistance
that's what 2029 is dad damn if it looks
anything if it looks anything like the
way we play trials I'm not looking
forward to
speak for yourself Craig
all right so what you know it up a
little
[ __ ] crank Alaska
yeah it's [ __ ] ask me later you gonna
ask me something weird
Craig man we're about to play I know
dude I'm here I'm putting this away when
we start don't worry dad we're going in
we're going in guys round two yes were
you bucko
hi ma'am a website made an article about
my complaint on the Instagram saying
Pettis can't contends ruffs decision to
check blood in the middle of locked
triangle damn right hundred yeah that
wasn't even be shouldn't even be a
[ __ ] thing it's more common sense
than anything I just I don't understand
I felt like I was taking crazy pills
yeah like everybody just seemed like it
was cool no works like here Dustin
because there's blood in anthony's eyes
we're gonna give you this you don't need
to escape this triangle well stop it
click and then just put you back in
guard
oh there's two warlocks yeah I mean I
don't know why he didn't stop it sooner
and he chose right dead to do it was
weird the whole thing was weird that's
too bad for Anthony though it was a good
fight up until then all right yeah Boyd
Walker
I choose heaven yeah we're together all
right a little back that way now if I
back out back up I [ __ ] up one temple
I'm sure you go over that all right it's
coming from behind me I need help
I gotta mother need I'm sure
I'm trying [ __ ] I was all [ __ ] up
there
[ __ ] sorry coach no no they did that's
why I tried to this dude's all over we
got a killer you gotta kill him before
we gotta kill something don't try
disarming because you keep looking at
this good I want I need your mind in
your heart in it I was here every time
going temple tell ya I hate keyhole dude
yeah I feel like Sudan because they get
us at so many different angles you're
gonna be even more stuck in [ __ ]
that's why I throw up a shield here see
I blocked this area I need help over
there
I'm just a man I can't I didn't know
where you were I'm setting
they're gonna get it I said it though I
wasn't worried about setting it right
away
yeah we gotta kill them you need that we
need to cover each other's backs man cuz
I'm running in like two three people I
don't have anybody helping me I'm just
gonna follow you oh just I'll follow you
tight to your hip
go wherever you're gonna go I'm right by
almost time I pulls back yeah Craig you
should like anticipate there they might
be there no I don't have it off to the
right there's one think about it all
back cuz they're trying to flank let's
let's kill this flank and there's one
Centon
yeah just help me over here
see that's more like it Wow so I'm get
chopping behind watch your back from
behind us yeah oh he got me defuse it be
true I got Rockets I'm trying to I got
my speakers are you good job Pikachu so
we got ya Pikachu yeah yeah but we got
to do more of that
are you streaming so and we gonna team
shoot to help him kill are you streaming
no I'm trying my computer's lag and I
may have to restart my computer
I don't something here for like and I
were going levels II follow Colt are you
going oh yeah
my bad my bad there's one there he could
choose he's hung in there there you go
alright coming through the hallway
oh come on go ahead set I'm gonna put
that up there there's one don't even
worry about that man kill that guy first
what the [ __ ] that guy's lag jump dude
get some revives going
nobody's revival yet [ __ ] get attacked
on the side dude you guys all got to
relax we're just yelling over each other
watch ah he's got rocket yeah everybody
gotta calm down we're getting way too
excitable and everybody should follow
coke pikachu's yeah man oh man I'm sorry
guys I just get so frustrated you know
yeah but let's not I mean it's it's it's
supposed to be hard
that's the point of trials just gotta
work together
and chill out I don't have a goodnight
Pikachu if I do I'll try to use one why
do we have to go in here to begin with
cuz I feel stuck every time we're here
it's just way they go yeah I'll be over
here I'm gonna have it gonna be
got that one Ellen's in this
I got a rockets Wow he got two Wow
where's II sins of the past stay here
they're gonna come through this bridge
get right in home battle this I saw two
of them and there was her behind her
behind need help I got him but I've got
[ __ ] no but that was a [ __ ] idea
I just you know it's like these guys
wronged me you know what's alright we
get too excited it's too early to get
this excited a [ __ ] guy no but else
dude and sucked get ready for more
supers they're about to have okay
I just stay here see what what way they
go all right it looks like they're
pushing temple
I hit I hit there we go
how'd that guy not die he rolled right
through my [ __ ] Rene dude they're
setting a keyhole
I tried nice okay let's go let's go help
him
oh my golden God doesn't work all right
we gotta get that thing I'll get it I'll
get it I'll get it
I think I got it yeah you got it yeah I
got it mmm good job right hey guys
really fast that was good man keyhole
like a keyhole all right [ __ ] they're
all there though [ __ ] we know we can
beat people at least you know at least
the good thing is not to go back and get
a card and use all those coins
I guess step it up cochlear Craig's
definitely nice
suck it I'll serve an armed one so sins
of the past is that the way to go then
just get that what about this if you
have it it's a raid it's a raid gun it's
a raid drop
you know what that's maybe why it's like
it's if that type of thing is affecting
the game
that's why I'm trying to get my mind
into this I've never gotten so much [ __ ]
I get this guy good monitor we don't
know every time we don't do that little
middle area I feel like we're getting
picked off it's that way we don't have
to go there we've done the two bikes
wait
would you prefer to get picked off
somewhere else I could say this what
Pikachu and you know me and you cuz I'm
sitting next to you I could see your
screen okay and you and Arthur be a team
right so cray what do we do well we
could just flank they don't link
together another well flank together
okay
so we try it together like glue just to
see that it's not much different we'll
try it what's it like being you we're
gonna do it all right team yeah all
right so hard to make sure you stay with
coke don't run off everywhere got it I
got it
okay Frank's coming home now he said I
know that doesn't help us any how's that
nightshade Arthur I love these guys you
got they got origin story
minor minor yeah you could try some
[ __ ] trials JD
that's the best in the best oh god I
hate these guys aren't that great okay
it's me and you okay Craig okay all
right just looks promising let's see
which way coke goes on we'll split and
cut them off okay I'm gonna go temple so
you guys go key so you going
let's go keyhole let's go left now just
stay here stay here don't go all the way
in here just shoot from here
yeah let's see if we see them all right
they're not over here so there's our
over here holes alright so so get this
get this
no you get it well here's the deed so
let's work together all right we hurt
that guy alright I'll get it
you get it I got your back all right
let's come around yeah how did that not
kill that guy
that day nice Craig see yeah but my
donto guys see the problem with that is
if they if they adjust and they all four
come to us we guys that'd be quicker
coming to the other it's just about
awareness you got to be quicker to get
to the other side because me and Pikachu
can't do [ __ ] when we get healthier
dudes
Craig did that work or no don't we got a
kill
better kill you all right let's not go
too far from them we can split up but
Lake if they go down the tunnel let's
stay left and tell you what so go pick a
side Craig you pick a side go do a side
I'll go middle always well well I was
gonna go middle I was saying he tried
throwing knife at me he's hurt
got that guy
I need help get it I got nobody there
got one
I'm by it all right they're in there huh
steadier your way on the other side yeah
I better use that thing I was weird soon
why he'll get that guy get his revive
there you go all right now you got to go
for it Oh watch out coke yeah I'm not
gonna get it I got him get it get it uh
no not good
all right that Rockets not bad though
cuz I got one guy let's go
oh sorry let's go this race to New
Year's without way I go metal I'm gonna
maybe go swallowing here alright let's
go this way
alright I'm gonna set it over here yeah
yeah set it Steve said it said it watch
your left
not letting together firearms hurt he's
hurt no I got rice thank you we said it
yeah we already said it I got I got two
nice
[ __ ] don't let him do it don't know like
I got shot what am I supposed to do I
doubt that [ __ ] grenade on my face oh
this is hard
you need to relax to lose if you look at
the KD I'm not the one not getting kills
I'm not naming names but one of us is
not playing up to their potential help
me well you're just running out in the
middle of nowhere I'll peek him out oh
my it's as simple as this it's as simple
as this if I become with me
we all think okay let's go ki home let's
go all right let's go up here let's go
up here I'm right behind you slow down a
little bit slow down a little bit I
gotta get out of the way so they don't
shoot us - oh god someone's down already
this guy's lagging hold on I can't go
through this grenade watch our back
shoot at these dudes and I'm just I'm
getting hit from [ __ ] every angle
here yeah
I know we have to take on Pikachu what's
going on with I don't know I don't
really we really need you here hey dude
leave them alone I'm just saying it just
killed that I know yeah you big bully on
no one to help me huh oh that's great he
uses a golden gun on me that was the end
of the round they had all their supers
all right so two and two didn't work
together I'm saying you're too excitable
too early and we just need to stick
together I don't like this [ __ ] level
it's like the snow I feel like I'm on
Hoth
I feel like I'm on Hoth all right let's
do one more let's stick together okay
she was changed should I go with Arthur
are we doing no no let's stay together
let's just all stay together did that
count or what no none of it counts not
until we get like a win like a game win
yet so this is when around
seemed like so hard tonight because it's
like Oh what are you looking at man get
your mind in the game I have to check
and make sure banana actually by the way
let's do a private one I don't want 80
people joining because who's run uh how
do we do that private you you made it or
Steven party controls make the party
invite only okay all right cool we're
good
what are we doing wrong words we're not
seeing shooting what's the life we're
not seeing shooting we're not sticking
together
yes Nev you should follow cook you're
really gonna seem shooting banana guys
you guys were doing good when guys did
the 2-2 squad we gotta get you some like
Zen stuff or something I'll take it they
sell Buddha box
that connection let's be let's get
serious here let's not joke around
trying to get some wheels here well no
one not seven wins
9 I know well we were just playing
different we have to if you have to warm
up as a team it's not like we're not
trying they all got 5 kills last game at
least you got some purple you got some
color and your shader uh-oh they're
looking at our stuff and getting
intimidated no look at them I could gold
look at their shaders oh you can't judge
a book by man that's true that guy's 260
doesn't matter dude look at their Katie
1.38 this guy's higher than us okay this
looks winnable let's do this I'm okay
let's do this crazy yeah we don't win
this we're done well you're supposed to
stay right behind coke I am what did I
tell you all right all right I'm with
him I'm stick I got my so let's jump
away stick to coke there there's two in
front of me I'm coming over here to
behind you I mean we're gonna go I'm not
gonna say it cuz I always say it I know
we know you're the best know
back up back up here oh [ __ ] good good
a guy disappeared we got one out get
tagged by the guy why oh man that guy's
with the miner at the UH nice de la vie
à la morte
all right there he's invisible like I
can't see but nice try nice try one was
like yeah you did good Pikachu had a
buddy win it is and he went to your left
yeah and I had that grenade on me I
couldn't see this follow Pope same thing
team shoot we got this can we check can
I try to flank but why we want her this
is the problem I had a set it temple
Wow I'm getting hit the nice side I need
help got him
got nice nice you guys it's absolute
what happened here's a fusion rifle
Phoenix down we got a good job got me
right in the face again close - all
right now yep more [ __ ] going game
coca-cola coca-cola
yo get utsuki oh yeah he's hurt he's
hurt bad
I need help [ __ ] melted me at that
annual ahead um what are you up coke
coming I'm not gonna be able to get to
you know they're pushing up on your cred
once linking to your website I know I
know I know I know
getting out of there I'm trying to get
coke no Stevie
[ __ ] I thought I had grenades oh [ __ ]
alleged or it's just name eletronic the
French name I don't know what they I got
the who knows Davis
let's go middle no one here
Oh God and the grenade got me out of
switch moves yeah I think we should have
stuck with temple [ __ ] yeah which is a
stuck temple temple or push through you
guys stop you stopped in there I know
temple and then you threw me off when I
came back around they're all there
well don't let me throw you off but just
follow me just follow me
that's like don't hide usually for you
but your pre think you're thinking pre
what I'm going to do you're thinking oh
I thought you were going temple but
that's not following me that's just you
assuming all right who are you now we're
stuck in this room team shot back to
shoot okay yeah he's hurt
where's that guy [ __ ]
yeah but we got three of them so let's
go watch this guy where's this last guy
like a [ __ ] right back him up I
got him I got him I'm coming and I'm
good defusing I'm defusing it up I got
it
Richard oradour what about him it said
he entered a chat did he enter our chat
no no dear chat okay ours is invite all
if he did I hope he hears this he's a
big [ __ ] he's not even close to the
Destiny player that Phoenix yes he is I
got him I got the goodbye babe yeah we
got one of them all right I'm gonna set
it at temple here we got to download
let's let them have come for the revives
that way we I can play for heavy here I
need help hey Craig one's gonna come
from your boost down I'm down Jesus
talking about
God why do I live all I made him wages
Nova nobody came for my life oh good job
Steve yeah I got him
hey go one last guy yep
well let him get it nope
you got it there we go nice good job you
guys
you know what that was my favorite round
I have to admit very fun so we did good
there Eric yeah it was good I got my I
got my arm my storm trance should I
start trances [ __ ] and you get
the opportunity to I'm gonna do it from
the side
are these days I think they're gonna
come around
I don't know it's good stuff I didn't
know you died [ __ ] I gotta get out of
here they're getting heavy you know what
I'm gonna send this out Richie Dora a
message I don't like him I don't like
his name okay
Frank's gonna Frank wants to get in a
Pikachu are you invited Frank yeah I got
you
okay that's six people right raid no
stop I mean we know how to do it now but
we actually care I'm a keyhole nobody
here maybe not oh god Frank hey Frankie
Frank we're doing x-files woman right
now all right four to four
and this got him
where's the last guy come in bridge Oh
Richard dory [ __ ] I hate you Jesus
Christ
I see Steve's doing well he's actually
actively wet yeah yeah one more one more
one more
I don't know I'm just kidding guys I
love Richard or unless 34 I see you
doing good thank you
yeah yeah you're second place which way
coke let's go keyhole follow me
I like this right are you a grenade is
gonna hit a couple of them
Oh strong chance that's us
there you go
[Music]
well they use they use the golden [ __ ]
next time Pikachu yellow yeah yeah I use
mine
yeah I don't have my golden where we got
there all keyhole keyhole I'm this
second I'm just checking don't go from
there I was just checking the seeing if
they're going that way so let's let's
push right here there's a slam he's hurt
I check out a shield oh god damn it -
that sucks [ __ ] ah now there's still
bananas guys frustrating Oh Coco second
there there's two behind you is the
finger that's probably I don't you went
to the wrong / no it's our movie follow
coke
he's on me yes what happens funny coke
killed hooks the batter clutch I'm just
saying that killed it all but you know
okay it was alright so that's our first
flawless I add they thought for sure
they had that last round did you guys
call sure yeah I get Frank in there so
you can put you okay alright Frank can
you fight Frank thanks Pikachu he's
gonna buy you off now okay you know I
will sometimes banana the uart there cuz
he's nice Lumbee oh babe I'm not I'm not
nice Oh where'd you get that adjudicator
sneaky Frank damn hot at Frank's weapon
she's got unorthodox weapons here
that's good is that good there's a
lobster gun good I've got an altar with
that haven't got now get you
crus once i'm done we could do something
together yeah well yeah Goldie [ __ ] yeah
I'm fine yeah no it's good hey Craig
tell them to check out the YouTube if we
how about we do we win then we get
popcorn
all right man wish I should have went oh
[ __ ] I wish I woulda went over gonna
come party here man I got so many nice
backdrop playing cuz I'll come over with
my TV next time yeah I just worry with
three it should but you never know never
know yeah what are those dude marchers
do I just saw you had do they make me
run faster that's why I run up with you
when you run that fast that's all I know
that's why I like they all have an t.o.p
DS man let's go temple should I turn my
mobility up just so I can run faster or
no oh there there there there there push
them back
it's alright we're getting rushed I got
him
traded what what happened we got
murdered real quick [ __ ] oh that's like
the [ __ ] out of us have you got to kill
Stevie you did good Steve no you didn't
it takes skill they're all flanking is
the problem there at temple be careful
here all right they're all back be right
back
how did that guy not die who the [ __ ]
I'm sorry
Jesus so we can we message that laggy
race that's [ __ ] [ __ ] to go Bobby
oh [ __ ] how do you give me that [ __ ]
sky ruffle so close behind us oh that's
great lady race but there's two in front
of me we're here oh [ __ ] coke watch out
I was [ __ ] it I shot at a guy who
filled up then another dude just popped
up in front of him that [ __ ] sucked
I damn it so we're not doing good are we
now but I don't warn you T now we got to
get used to everybody how we play and
somebody's flanking Steve [ __ ] Frankie
Warren right yeah I tried to dodge Anna
what the [ __ ] is going on here guys
first buddy's douzo who's up first what
happened [ __ ] [ __ ] okay what do I do
here
well good you know I'm just happy I
killed leggy raise I don't care if we
lose it won't look good you competitive
just got do it for the daily count I
don't even think these guys are that
gray we're just not playing like team
very well top of the flink all right
yeah actually they're amazing they're
all flanking right there we are in the
fridge oh me oh man [ __ ] come away
well combine us [ __ ] yeah
we're just getting to fly out flanked by
these dudes I did not have their [ __ ]
specials are they gonna get them right
now cuz this is ridiculous
[ __ ]
watch out watch out this sucks
so reality check there huh yep [ __ ]
that sucked
got a single kill Jesus Christ well
let's do one more
we've got a warm-up only new aspect is
we have how do I redo the trials of the
nine and just recent progress reset
progress everyone reset the trials
progress everyone do it yeah I'm good
what do you want I did it for a couple
and then come back to I mean that's up
to you guys man Frank it's up to you man
how you feeling I'm down to do more
trials alright let's break up let's
break out team so let's meet Craig and
then Frank and coke stick together teams
of two let's do let's do you and coke
and me and Frank yeah I think you're
gonna be good with coke
yeah I'm gonna be with you
all right yeah
we have fun or what is this font I'm
sorry I didn't mean to say [ __ ] I
wouldn't leggy it leggy raise whatever
her name is
good job you two what are you doing who
you texted I'm sexting Griffin dude
what's your problem okay
you just we'll talk later about yeah
mania Steve yeah Frank if we get on
popcorn baby I want to popcorn what
popcorn popcorn so coke
talk to me baby like what what do you
remove it's gonna be like what see where
they go that's how we see what way were
flanking here
okay so right when we see can we back
out of that room there's like three ways
leading in there oh look at these guys
are badass oh my God look at the shaders
oh my god
no this guy has one four nine forty oh
my god look at this oh look at his armor
- did you see that that guy went for oh
my god no how do you know he's got no
joke oh I'm with you I'm still a trainer
how do you pikachu's all honest dude
okay somebody's lagging somebody's for I
bet it's their team - [ __ ] [ __ ]
alright Frank where are you Frank let's
go this way Frank
I'm with you yep let's come around there
they're over there Frank here okay don't
speak out there yep get back okay
there's one guy over here he's just
poking don't don't go out there Steve
all right let's go around this way Frank
he's poking you got the heavy yeah help
me er let's get this guy I got that guy
goddamn it with some help in the hallway
here sorry coach I mean what are these
guys cheating dude no I had the main
ingredient yeah one sorry all right now
you're good let's let's start let's
follow them and break off on down all
right you're gonna go that way let's go
this way
watch out there on bridge [ __ ] I tried
to back up
it's your left Frank you're left behind
you below them
[ __ ] we're dancing maybe we should all
stick together a for you guys trying
yeah maybe we should stick together our
before Craig scopes call right I'll
stick i'll stick together I didn't say
to break off I'm cool with that
what do you think yeah that's what I
normally do I was all Coca's the man
let's just hit hard right here how's
that I'm right here dude
yeah was getting I got two of them
I needed help there you know yeah what
are you doing man I can't read your
Livi's come on never mind all right yeah
are you ordering food again Frank so
help me God
no a hand for my flight information okay
at the most inopportune time I know us
all right not this team though I mean
this guy's one trials 443 times I mean
that's crazy that's too many times now
they're all there
you see nothing let's try that we just
trying to do better
oh my come on they're all their [ __ ]
they're just wrong there's this team
shooting a wall and together
good job banana yeah they're just
sticking together watch now it's
different okay maybe we should regroup
if you guys want to take a break or
something huh crucible dude I I just
it's it's gonna be sweaty it's trials
man it's just this is the way this is an
elbow we just start to play like what
the [ __ ] do you you're right next to me
then everybody runs away and I'm getting
shot at I don't know what's happened
damn shoes - patty oh [ __ ]
I'm behind you let's go for it got him
it's a regular crucible either spirits
up
so he [ __ ] [ __ ] catch it
yeah we can take a break and do normal
rate some whisper raid I mean we have
yes don't worry I've never done it it's
trials of Osiris
I mean trials of the nine we're just I
don't know what's going on I just
finished I was gonna say me banana coke
and people do know how to do it I don't
I don't feel like doing I don't want to
play PvP you don't you want to play PvP
it's Sunday trials of the nines go on
and we just need more communication we
don't we're like not playing as a team
all right let's yeah all right fine I
don't care I mean it's gonna we're gonna
do better here cuz all the sweaty people
are doing trials that's the difference
whoa exotic Inc so no Reid could have
done a couple levels you do it now we
have coke and Stevie we be
as an audience the only folks not
talking the dog part the parts I think
they could do I'm tired dude I've been
traveling all day yeah yeah
we go up there see that's some good
that's good motivation there let's get
three wins and trials better okay you
know I mean I know but we got to get
three wins we've all got one all night
well yeah Craig
are we just not good like why are they
so much better than us
nah man we've just played a guy who
played 443 wins and you know how much
coke please
I really don't play la house honestly
yeah but you played a lot more than me
and I did I did I did in the beginning
and I mean let's see if our response is
on the chat because I know Aero plays
like all the time I'm just saying like
Craig might actually have a point here
no I actually rarely I played for the
first couple weeks a lot and then after
that it's just like just prove my point
I get it you suck you don't play
[Laughter]
yeah see
what's the trial team cook I know you
like that win today
oh man it's about time Brown the Browns
are still one less right yeah they all
ate the team are like Mexican the truck
see what trunk sweetie today what a
classic like Kim Jong oh yeah we can't
done what was funny
where you going Frank
yeah I [ __ ] just rocket like taking a
rocket yep you know I was gonna happen
where did Frank what next week or this I
just got back I was in Seattle how that
going to Sacramento next week nice
sometimes before 10 o'clock [ __ ] dammit
I ran into and I put my gun all wacky
wacky tobacco that down the left hold me
get him coke it seems so much easier
doing this huh
yeah cuz they're not try hards all the
cards are doing trial that's great
that's great
let them talk I don't know what you're
talking
I'm saying that's great that all they're
all playing [ __ ] trials you can play
this and [ __ ] have some fun yeah and
get better video like I don't I don't
see what's fun about trial especially
that math in that game site man I just I
don't like it make me hate Frank oh
there we go
dad damn they're not oh my god yeah
there's no two of them camp camp in that
spot right yeah but I'll get it
god damn come on banana I know we're
losing here Hill's gift man
thing is so ridiculous let's go let's go
let's take these guys okay oh my god
yeah just play regular cruisin in you
guys will mob on people yes I'm fine
alone all weekend long table come on
boom Wow
[ __ ] it I didn't see him I must have
been in biz nailed it the kid he is good
the stable
oh that was you yeah that's right run
away I knew you had it
no what are you eating Frank oh my god
tell they you banana what nice
what now I get the leftovers from
earlier hand as a handle warmed them up
deep that's all right like an extra to
Marciano's I've been there it's good
stuff this is the last round or there's
one
this is the last challenge it won't go
back in the trials I think we're ready
well I think we're ready dude come on
look nice I'm down to do whatever you
guys want to do Steve wants to play coke
coach responses hilarious
[Laughter]
let's play for real let's get off your
phone Pikachu because I'm talking to
your mom ya know yeah but that's kind of
going far I'm saying as far as far as I
know I agree I mean he's not playing
this I would have to die first dude
eternity destiny
I mean gameplay you know what I'm saying
okay here we go who we playing against
we get these stickers I got the shirt I
want to tear down my pillow Pikachu
a game a Donald Trump sticker you get
you oh nice I got a shirt I got a shirt
oh okay all right let's see this guy's
only 24 at least he's not 39 or 443 this
guy's almost 200 they were coke
stay with coke I wish again shitty teams
cuz it's everybody wants before the dies
off they're going far they're all left
this hallway well I'm gonna set this car
but I'm setting need help they're coming
from behind I got a triple team there
I'll let you but
there we go one up top what is it up top
one up top you just got me dude that's
what I'm talking about dude yeah good
job Craig yes my tango corporate Craig I
saw you do that oh yeah
now let's go stick together there's all
right keel fine I got back up back up
back up
I just get out of there
we should come around I'm good I'm good
I'm popping them I'm gonna get this I
got one I got one
[ __ ] [ __ ] I have one oh he's got rocket
ship he's got wrong gotcha thanks got a
rocket
there are legit team well maybe not it's
got the same [ __ ] that mom you guys are
legit team
oh god Pikachu swear to God
wfe is still a team trail temple time we
can't obviously a continuous 13 I'm
gonna run in and try to set set it I was
terrible with other factor for my god
there phangan - OH - are you guys [ __ ]
again yes sir give me my help
nothing I'm so what can I do dad
I mean I said it [ __ ] oh my god
what's this wall with me here no they
already know they're coming this way
I'm hurt there you go nice TV there's
one right there
he's so hurt
he's so hurt that guy good job guys oh
we got we're tied so that's good it's
got a keyhole let's throw them off there
any oh they're always there everyone
always goes keyhole [ __ ] I don't have
anything you try and get your they're
just they're just taking they're just
don't you yeah that's fine that's fine
just come around come around I'll bet it
temple I got Rockets all right so do
they come in they're all coming around
Oh No oh that hurt dude I just saw that
rocket hit you oh wow I miss that was
painful to watch gopher yeah how did
that not ya underwater sounds just stops
you from dying from raucous we're doing
one kill I didn't say anything I just
said are you having fun or not if you if
you asked me like 20 times in a row I
don't know what that's supposed to mean
that dude should have been dead
instantly I don't know how we didn't
yeah yeah I [ __ ] threw Agron I missed
that's my experience I got a guy chiming
in my ear 75 times you got a beautiful
monitor I'm not dude I didn't see
anything I didn't say any I'm playing
alright let's go
I'm not looking at my phone am i all in
Coke
well that's just great
paulus grenade but I don't know what you
guys are back there that's once that's
where I'm confused by well I was peeking
I was a geeking problem and I dipped
just want to see where they were going
now you have that guy you tell you know
we know we can beat these dudes we're
just not sticking together is that the
last round
like nobody liked it it's just not it's
not [ __ ] going you've got a kill oh
great I got a kill great let the record
show who's giving a [ __ ] let's look
let's look at the stats stats don't lie
let's look at the stats see what's going
on here
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I'm fun now twelve saying though is
we're not we're not having a problem
you're saying we need to teach you
we're not team feel it's not happening
yeah no matter why don't we do something
no I that's the last thing I want to do
[Music]
[Laughter]
if we keep playing I don't care about
the rate I want to do I want to as one
unit all right let's give it one more
shot and then we'll play Cruz but
seriously let's all try climb on top you
know I never say let me let me okay and
I'm I'm good I'm good I'm good up close
with the hand cannon if I don't have any
but like you guys are trailing so
[ __ ] hard far behind like I can't get
anywhere unless I got people backing me
up I can't [ __ ] do it
we got people and I
no method where you don't go I think in
there we just all go on the outskirts
I'm better on the running one way we're
running one way but everybody's looking
a different direction dude it blows my
mind like everybody like that guy that
came down the tunnel there's two ways
from the tunnel there's only one way a
guys coming from how he survived four of
us looking down a tunnel I don't
understand it that's what I'm you know
what I agree with you no that doesn't
make sense
you need y'all gotta pull the looking in
different directions we got look at the
same direction all right okay you know
they're gonna be behind it all right so
along this way I'm looking at radar
there's a guy right in front of me we
yeah we got him yes there we go come
over but no one help me shoot that guy
okay now we help that get that guy that
guy's hurt out there get the guy out
there get me it get me get me up Craig
get me up we can't yet hold on hold on
see I got him I can't in a can find
again trying to protect him
now Steve do you have a token at the
bottom right you can get one of us up
I'm setting the charge okay can you get
me or somebody up no you can't no I just
covered the orbital gonna go for a
revive oh that's just great I died the
computer monitor yeah try not to look at
you and land you're going crazy over
there if there's a guy that comes up
here okay so you see the lower-left get
ready to this guy this guy don't down no
he's still there
yes yeah that's that guy like that all
right
follow me
oh wow that was the strongest male in
the [ __ ] history of this game
there's one coming around that body
gonna get him get him I heard him I
heard him fight defuse defuse defuse I
think that's diffused already I got it I
got it
Wow we can dance dance Steve show my
dance there you go yeah okay was that
what you meant
yes okay
there you go
it's all radar our Institute
cheerleading oh okay
great job Craig you're doing great all
right so now watch watch all right
no right don't die take cover
don't peek out there all right to our
right there's gonna be one coming around
come on I [ __ ] tag that guy he's
right by the temple by the bomb
watch out Steve we traded oh [ __ ]
goddamn it I'm getting heavy cuz I
thought he was gone
flowers two of them right there can we
win this I'm not stopping
we're trying all right follow me
keyhole wall here that looks like
they're going yep there go on temple all
right so that's round keep following you
or what - team up on this game he's hurt
that salutes I gotta go all right we got
a defuse it man go let's yeah go for the
second where Frank yes no let me get it
let me get it oh [ __ ] god damn it I'm
holding them off here and I hold them
off Go Go Go Go Steve another one dude
whoa whoa [ __ ] I'm dead wasted heavy
like an [ __ ]
there you go Steve watch out he's got
his Eddie Eddie no - you got it we got
to rush that guy another day long it
doesn't matter if we I'm sorry I was in
the heat of the moment man I want to
kill him so bad no I know I know but I'm
saying I know I [ __ ] one drop if we
can't win this and we are wfe
I'm not gonna take that moniker away all
right temple yeah let's go keyhole
we got numbers now just go far left
though there we go yeah they're not here
you said it yeah I'm slamming up new
camera how did he survive he slamming
he's almost dead don't let him don't let
him not yeah I just tell them all the
bathroom oh [ __ ] don't let him do that
grenade oh don't do that don't let them
do that you got it you got it
that was Frank you did it guys Pete -
this whole time no I'm just kidding mmm
all the time [ __ ] I'll buy you pizza or
win this [ __ ] that and the guy won hold
on the best so hurry me the guys saw her
right there
help me help me out into the great Steve
Steve Steve got the bomb the bomb baby
we're so happy we are wfv we're the
worst we can use all the leverage okay
temple I got my dad call like a stork
all follow me though there's a big door
Oh TV yeah that was that's why you gotta
say early dude going left
you know no know if you hear temple and
you're going the other way
stop go the other way quick going don't
faking you gotta go in the same [ __ ]
way you guys they still made it that I
still made it to fight in temple yeah
[ __ ] them don't you don't have to chase
them
nice DVD this guy wants the Crotty chop
with me or what I've got a chocolate in
Chopin bro all right which ways captain
captain coke go this way
do you hole away well they're all right
there
oh that he should be dead there you go
yeah that sucked
just one more round coke guys somebody
ever wanted to revive somebody but
school just go kill the guy yeah kill
him before you arrive I want to revive
his guys though
please doll a lot of her life those guys
swear to God all right just got running
- no way - Marat nice Frank good job
filthy Titan okay thanks for getting me
up there at the end there's no time
hey I'm kidding I still got my storm
call
I'm going bread yeah they're all down
there go Bridge go Bridge gonna come
around them oh okay that was ridiculous
ran behind the wall but where are they
yeah there are y'all back there I decide
mijo [ __ ] them
yeah can I get you up Craig no uh yeah
yeah yeah they're not looking at me
let's go ki home let's go ki all now
remember you guys yeah I said it
this guy mister he's got rocket
launchers the longest yeah get a pump
cones are doing the twelve yeah baby
yes great good job Frank Wallace out of
you
Pikachu can we kick you from the party
now take the best pop I've got a message
from chicky babe wait tiffy babe say I
said I won V Ford y'all multiple times
my god y'all are terrible I'm twelve
seven point nine we should all pretend
like we're five is that what this
chuckle we didn't get messages Oh cuz
you're the best out of our group that's
why we
he know who knows why let's not pretend
what's his name man Oh Ron I just said
him that and I said scared scared to
join party because he won't see what a
[ __ ] so many [ __ ] [ __ ] dude it's
ridiculous Griffin's getting on sir
of course he did this is great where do
you get this target
did you tell her he said we're all
terrible do you tell me where the worst
party ever because does he know how to
check our pocket and check out our
podcast and then I'll find out who I am
you know it's like light it's not too
buttery read the back of it what takes a
minute look look look at the back no
artificial ingredients no preservatives
tree nut free peanut free dairy free
gluten free Wow Craig good choice
popcorn [ __ ] free give me a laptop their
time out Eric coming oh there's a buyer
you want to see yourself eating popcorn
look here you eating popcorn why is
there my strength
I'm Robson next because there I'm
sitting next to you I'm sitting next get
your head in the game we're in eternity
come on here we go yeah what's the chair
look like you're like do they like us to
think of funny no destiny for Dusty's
dead - Bob - uh-oh McLovin Hill 33 he's
like Frank's guy looks the Sikkim send
me a song man this is a to Paul word
we're facing a good team here - please
oh these guys are no joke
oh no shoe my misc
I think that carry to my dad
then are we doing here let's go we
follow come whole wall keyhole there go
on tempo you know they said it
come on we needed to be quicker on that
this should've had that guy oh how does
he not yet yeah Frankie all that Coke
I'm okay I'm back I'm good no I guess
I'm getting one killed when I had to we
could add them both got to him down I
should have had that one guy that sucked
on my part
let's go Kehoe
[ __ ] I'm brother get the killed housing
not [ __ ] dead dude hon do we armed it
or what yeah just his melee is way
stronger than mine
God how there's our garbage Steve you're
in the way wrong place they're gonna
defuse it's on the other side it's my
flower [ __ ] yep there they're all
there they're gonna confuse it there any
more people are bad
Jim's done it's my fault I'm sorry is
the popcorn got me off the key dude oh
we found his pizza don't come to my chat
and try to coach me [ __ ]
here's coach in here I don't know
guys ruff I can't back out they're
flanking us
I got ya good job [ __ ] man come come
back God taking what same [ __ ] [ __ ]
do it I don't know what we were doing
there
that was off just go zero telling you of
all the problems you're doing the rest
of you [ __ ] gonna have help
killing this guy [ __ ] Larry Kong see how
that hat treats them all right let's go
up by it where is this dude
ah [ __ ] [ __ ] in the ass there's dude
going [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my god I just can't shoot my [ __ ]
weapon they keep breaking their system
doing crazy movements man they're like
going in and out weaving in and out
there's a guy in the shooting that guy
13 shooting in there - we are gonna
stick together we gotta stick together
yeah push this wall first guy that comes
up we [ __ ] kill them this I there's
two back there
there we go there we go we do now they
have to defuse round yep where is this
guy
they're nice Phoenix do a little dance
like I didn't message me back
I feel sad now he's still thinking about
the guy from the last game yeah that was
awesome that's the past right now we're
a real time babe don't talk to me don't
talk I can't [ __ ] early Americans
still play better Oh know where I'm
coming back all right
Oh Nolan come on I died dude and I'm
just saying I took out two but then they
were flanking me they were pranking you
flanking or laying on top of them
yeah they're planking me from sense a
new thing clanking really hit this
channa think they're gonna kill you get
up nice
[ __ ] where's that storm
back up where is he
[ __ ]
going for that defuse this is the spot
all right girls like it I got got sniped
farming jukebox we're not gonna make it
goddamn it
all right now just sent a message from
Griffin nice we gotta fight yeah you
must be on there you all jump out man I
gotta go to bed
I gotta say what yeah what [ __ ]
I gotta train hard tomorrow I got a
fight coming up All Right Scoop
got a breakup old record let's let's do
some competitive I didn't say anything
I'm just saying man we need you buddy
[Music]
in smoked here alright let's go to the
guys want to go to tower real quick yeah
I got was that what no no we're getting
video hey did that guy hooky there yeah
did that guy message you back
no no banana just follow me after you
pick it up yeah I'm coming what a party
I'm already broadcasting what's the deal
yeah we've been broadcasted alright yeah
you're late to that son first Craig is
here he's smoking Craig told me to ask
you and then you open ring Frank smokes
I don't know Craig smoked yeah Creek
smokes did he smoke bad when when I
visited Leslie and he is [ __ ] smoking
real bad my girlfriend is taking nail
polish off her toes right now so I'm
getting a contact high from the hood
from the pollen nail polish yeah or
they'll pause remover that's great
hey all right be right be right back
where you been pika - I've been helping
the banana get I'm just playing he's got
his monitor going please tell me you're
taking pictures of you guys playing in
the center that's gotta be a picture
[ __ ] nerd are you recording Griffin
I'm did you have enough for a raid still
dude I want to read it's not fun for me
I don't care I don't care
the Raiders no there's no reason to play
it but I imagine it looks like that
scene from Jabba the Hutt yeah Jesus
Frank it's actually a very nice picture
I like it Griffin it's cute I gave
Stevie a space backdrop that's like the
tenth time you've mentioned that tonight
how about a couple wins how about we win
a couple we got a bright in Graham we're
gonna go up that I'm gonna go clean out
my [ __ ] post my post office oh I got
a new new vehicle some shaders where'd
she go just do suck see alright already
we should get her out we should get all
the girlfriends to play that's alright
are you guys ready to go to orbit what's
the deal you want to go you guys want to
play some crucible or not a guy just
messaged me talking [ __ ] I tried that I
invited him to the party but okay so
it's coastal plain think Buster Douglas
went to bed before he beat Mike Tyson
yeah what was the thing
about getting your exotics and then
taking off the taking off the is that or
do you dismantle it how do you get the
mod from it you just dismantle the
exotic I think that's how you get them
this guy sent us our had weight tell him
thank you he said thank you there you go
where are we doing the trial don't have
to reset my trials progress oh we do
yeah I'm going to I'm going to go fall
asleep but well I'm gonna fall asleep to
watching you guys play it's gonna be
[ __ ] cuz we thought that and then
Pikachu pika - [ __ ] we almost got
their bananas here banana we talked
about it though i we think you miss
advatage yeah but you know what I can't
blame them Allah because he just didn't
want correctly come well did you guys
ask I don't know do we know we know
Pikachu shady you're the first one
always
you hear that lemon oh that's hilarious
hey babe how do you feel about me
playing destiny yeah well she's asleep
Wow
Oh God look at these that's green oh the
guy's got a tone patrol nothing good I
think good you know my Eric that Bush
for lame
tomorrow okay yeah probably likes the
feel of it so we don't have to go now
what do we do we just kind of run with
their kids follow great that's cut offer
watch out there's two over there there
we go guys I said but let's there was a
guy back there he's running away he's
going bridge let's go back let's all
right let's go this way
okay that was [ __ ] straight upset
defense
oh sorry every problem you guys owe me
I'll make the I'll make the make the
call I have studied the ways of coming
here we're getting flanked to the back
that's just great just [ __ ] I won got
lit up traded hi man was a good night
huh I said it gots a photocell huh well
yeah we gotta gym enough already what
the [ __ ] dude yeah don't give up now ah
the last guy live for not Griffin's
alive
get him up he's going to the point
oh my god
does this count as a this counts yes
what yeah baby good I came here to kill
your Jesus I know I'm trying to get
these guys back up bro
all you do is run off right here I don't
know dude this is where I hate the
[ __ ] I say we do the red we're
literally the worst foreign team ever
look at this and banana we could do the
raid at least a couple levels of it I
don't know about that yeah we know we
know how to be more what happened I ate
all of those the face I don't know why
we're doing this without jumped on your
head my friend
dicks no sure you're gonna step they're
gonna set over at that temple there they
go
let's go temple these people are lying
dude I'm [ __ ] tired design the
[ __ ] head
watch out watch out for the echo did you
guys meet your TV's yeah I try to get
you up man I'm telling you there's lag
right here hey guys I'm doing my part
all right
supers here in a second he's doing good
with that sword frame I'm gonna go pee
hole like you just said don't run me at
all now you're running off kiha I said
key all mr. Anderson oh you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
that's how we get inflamed getting
franked
what hey you got kill I do know Whoopi I
gotta kill I'm sorry I've no idea we're
doing the raid Oh angry good to do this
one more time that wasn't good
Wow there points to housing efficiency I
know that's good you know change your
weapons now I don't want to play I know
interest I'm just telling you we know
how to do it you got to choose it's
actually pretty easy I know that's why I
explained now that we know how to do it
it's really not that hard
know what you know how to do it it's
easy and the doc
[Music]
we just make a point of trying to win
one round here I know I'm with you
brother I am so with you well who wants
to be like Mike I don't want a leader
Frank you want to leave you see you like
oh all together to one area split up at
that area dude you can take that by the
way from the stoner and they still
didn't fix that [ __ ] I burners oath
that's what you're using yeah I know but
they're gonna have white might all
better Devils oh this guy's got 94 times
94 wins okay way to psych us out oh this
guy's got 306 me well that's just great
oh won't we do just get out of this this
is the pointless well let's try her
brute squad
oh okay who's the who's a leader where
we got this Griffin is I'm following
he's right go together
there we go
there we go team shots but they're doing
it at the other place
let's go middle let's go up let's go
let's go falling you Frank are shooting
your gun start shooting your gun
if Anika open the door yeah
no the other one yeah no you tried
there's painful for me to get shot while
I was doing that it's okay
we both got killed I just want to kill
that guy all right well let's go to
Temple let's do the same thing okay like
I to people go to people go that way if
somebody [ __ ] yeah there you go I'll go
with Craig and you guys go the other way
through the middle there and get your
head in the game I don't know how he
didn't get that guy that's true we
should have gone
Wow - Eric C [ __ ] man
I got nothing get their disgusting what
did you just read I mean the scoreboard
looks so terrible I know
tell me about it I said we cut through
middle yeah take leave pick block
corporate Craig I swear to god I'm gonna
kick right now min Pikachu three seconds
what are you the president shot in the
back like that fantastic
yeah you got a couple of kills Stevie
don't feel good about it I mean cuz
we're as a team we're getting
slaughtered
that's why pop it up pop that dust me go
Frank go go Franco what the hell is
Conover's what kind of name is ice
[Laughter]
on what on Instagram I gotta give as
pretty awesome that was awesome Griffin
oh sweet yeah
now let's go to keyhole yeah all right
all gonna be this Dukey oh yeah I'm into
the keel ice guy just Nova bombed
everybody up there that was cool we've
done the knife for you guys one do the
knife all at least we can get something
out of that I'm doubtful yeah we can
walk you through yeah we are how we're
gonna break this team how we're gonna
break it up
all right let's just do crucible all
right
you want to go competitive or quick play
can
yeah I like
will dominate this
made this we got it
just being real will you get you know
what dude you got a push there if I need
to yeah quit looking looking at me yeah
cuz we're getting our asses kicked
that's why you think we're gonna get rid
of coke take it to the hole
I don't know Craig bad we're really bad
huh so that map is really bad cancer
yeah coke hates that map he's tired of
playing buddy it's like a mighta map all
day I'll [ __ ] you coke what do you say
who's that sound so proper ooh banana
banana Steve
what guys watching Craig played makes me
want to burn my eyes out Oh contraire
sir do you have any Grey Poupon on your
map
watching you do anything makes me want
to puke
come back the truth alright what'd you
guys think of the trailer for the new
DLC you'll see it in the pockets and you
know what you guys haven't slowed me one
throw me one dude we're the worst fire
team I'm just sitting here looking at
the screen man talking with your mouth
full of [ __ ] dick oh why are we doing
competitive we should just quit played
now it's the same [ __ ] no it's not
we have a change here
oh honey yeah whoa oh I got the helmet
how many did you get banana 181 nice
they said it I Steve get me Steve this
got daddy's FK oh I got those the gang's
all here
all right around I thought you're going
to sleep not bailing on us because
you're poor Kady he started rain also
finish it - I got guns poking me I'll be
a gunfight alright I think Co can
survive bullets Wow we'll see
we just played like this the whole time
people on trials their guns are faster
it's because there's they're all try
hard they have yeah well then map
awareness they know how to I don't know
[Music]
parents have disposable income I laugh
at that
[Laughter]
do I kill with people's girlfriends I
thought you must say you kill people's
girlfriends that sounds more like it
damnit
should I had that guy
oh my god notice notice how he didn't
respond that's some real he just did you
just did he say I'm gonna [ __ ] kill
you you good did you get the Scout ref
also yeah turn the pot with coke man
he's not a plane anymore
there's someone say pot you know he said
it he's sandy handy because he rubs
people the wrong way here we go this is
why I should have setup go to sleep cuz
of my KD skates looking forward knees
should I bring my xbox that's right oh
wow we really are the worst fire team
ever first worst friend team ever
oh [ __ ] where's that where's that dude
coming from 5 and 1 was ran' diseases
the parlour why have you been to
Bellevue yet know what they're doing
we're losing now okay yeah cuz we're
talking about hotels yeah I don't think
I'm on the bottom just watch she's gonna
end up on the bottom I probably will
what the [ __ ] gangster guardian nice
good kill
goddamn this thing lasts for [ __ ]
ever alright who's here that I can
revive nice TV be on top right now watch
this oh that's just great I just went
into for a suicide mission
let's go Frank let's do it over here
I'll block us oh you're with me Jesus
I'm second on the board dude I don't
know what you're talking about
[Laughter]
you know Frank what are you doing Oh God
no one saw that right yeah he said you
just made yourself look foolish Craig
yeah what doesn't he go to sleep like 10
hours ago because he was so tired
Canadian so it was
[ __ ] dude yeah I don't even know if
you want to run me through the guys
stupid that's that's always helpful
defusing good job Steven oh [ __ ] [ __ ] I
got stuck in some [ __ ] [ __ ] do we lose
they won
Craig [ __ ] you sir they use all these
two of their supers like a bunch of
[ __ ] idiots
yeah but they still got a golden gun so
be careful it went the other way
won't the other way do they do go let's
go they're gonna set over here
I could use some help I need help
but nobody's oh go on oh it's him Frank
get a Frank get a Frank
I can't believe it I can't believe it we
started off so strong it's cuz the moral
support
what's it what's Pikachu do because you
want to play some [ __ ] nah Mattie no
come on Frank come on let's do one more
one more
we got it go and pick it up and put me
I'm out this is the Craig Redemption
tour right here you got this Craig I
believe in you corporate support
[Music]
[Music]
I'm just playing my game you see that my
doing he's bringing wrestling things
into it
honorable mention 13 ollie okay
we're just camping over in that [ __ ]
corner annoying oh they got the heavy
well they didn't beat um up can I get
something I'll put this dude he's so
[ __ ] hurt I mean I don't know where
everyone oh my god dude this is why I'm
[ __ ] bottoming oh you should have
shot him you're just hiding behind that
thing they're hiding there's this guy
let's go go let's go let's go there we
go these guards guards killers guy
where'd he go what the [ __ ] is this dude
dude hydrated then
oh I didn't not this - there we go see
Craig at the top and Craig just a crazy
tension towards my legs gonna win this
family back don't even get the joke my
family's in goes like applying the yeah
I was like I know I know it's your god
Frank I love you Frank
no you can break them down no no no no
you can sort coming yeah we traded all
right they're coming together we got a
group up
Gregg on twitch right now yeah yeah
wait you know I gotta look at Steve's be
I love easy brake is on
what's his name Steve you are OS [ __ ]
man I [ __ ] that up
uh yeah turn I'm gonna turn on my phone
next out very good text [ __ ] alive okay
we're playing running a game dude why we
playing Oh
you [ __ ] [ __ ] there you go Tom oh my
god policy yeah we gotta win guys
disgruntled employees it's a great girl
we got stick together guys
I'll watch out there's a guy right there
oh I wasn't good can't stand shacks man
shut up facts need help
[ __ ]
he's just camping out with his mida I'm
looking at his skis right now it's crazy
to me
look camping out of my mind I'm [ __ ]
shooting [ __ ] I don't want you
[ __ ] to talk about if I do
wallets cuz of some [ __ ] if I suck
at some [ __ ] it's not sucking y'all
yeah I should be your name some [ __ ]
watch how he's coming Griffin they're
tethered where's this dude I hate when
they show up on the [ __ ] bed quick
thing
I didn't know you use yours - Stevie
[ __ ] I just wasted coaxing your folks
watching your feet yeah so funny
you okay Craig yeah oh my god shut the
[ __ ] up and trying to win this match we
can't [ __ ] kill these dude thank what
am I supposed to do by myself well it
was to get that one guy but back up he's
got another grenade see back to that oh
good one
you got two kills that was good I try it
no you did
I'm desperate trying to be that's not
the point of the game the point is to
beat the other team we get that in our
head okay not a win it for that all go
hear the word expire -
five life man didn't I win that ahead
Stevie let's work together we're sitting
together let's work together why are you
Lola Griffin [ __ ] you
that [ __ ] [ __ ] you just another
tether one of those tethers do minute it
like shook my [ __ ] around oh yes we lost
this huh no what happened to us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]